dans cette cuve se prépare la pâte pour
la fabrication quotidienne des petits
biscuits numéro un des ventes de la
biscuiterie de chambord depuis 40 ans le
pas les solognots il en sort chaque
année 50 tonnes de cette chaîne de
fabrication
le créateur a été agriculteur à l'époque
avait une énorme exploitation duff ils
n'arrivaient plus forcément écouler ses
productions et plutôt que de jeter les
produits s'est décidé à fabriquer à
créer un biscuit
il a fait plusieurs livres de recettes
il a trouvé une recette qui était au
raisin des raisins du beurre des oeufs
de la farine et du rhum brun simples et
efficaces sont bien entre blancs la
biscuiterie de chambord en quoi 45
personnes réparties entre ses boutiques
dans le loir et cher et en indre et
loire et ses deux ateliers de production
c'est un mâle yves que la plus grande
partie des biscuits est fabriqué
en cinq ans la biscuiterie rembauché 25
personnes julie va bientôt intégrer
l'équipe en cdi
elle est formée par mélanie la plus
ancienne de l'atelier de fabrication tu
originaire de malik donc je connais à
biskri de chambord depuis toute petite
j'ai toujours mangé les gâteaux nouveaux
jeux très content de travailler ici ça
crée une fierté parce que c'est un
produit qui maintenant à 40 ans qui est
parti de rien et qui s'est diversifiée
avec les années et qui fonctionne très
bien
la fabrique artisanale tient bon face
aux grands groupes agroalimentaires pour
ça aussi
elle a une recette on conserve la
tradition donc clairement le palais
sogno le petit four cerise tout ce qui a
fait la renommée de la biscuiterie on
les conserve en état et on perpétue la
tradition clairement et après par contre
on s'attaque à innover énormément
énormément
ces dernières années on a peut-être
développer je les ai pas compte et
honnêtement mais au moins au moins une
trentaine de biscuits parmi les
nouveautés qui marche bien
des biscuits salés de plus en plus
tendance mais aussi la ligne de produits
bio et sans gluten